sous une robe sûr sensation
bonjour et bienvenue dans zone europe /
sensation une émission enregistrée au
parlement européen de bruxelles est
réalisée en association avec tv 78 voici
le sommaire de ce nouveau numéro
l'eurodéputé allemand jan christoph
hudgens sera notre invité l'occasion de
revenir avec lui sur l'année 2021
désigné comme année européenne du rail
ce jour là le 1er janvier 2002 c'est le
passage à l'euro les billets et pièces
sont introduits dans 12 pays et 308
millions d'habitants sont concernés les
superstitions en europe avec evelyne
keller auteur du livre 300 une
superstition celle opportun on
s'intéressera aujourd'hui aux traditions
liées aux gi mais avant que fait
l'europe dans notre région un exemple
tout de suite
saône robe l'europe dans ma région
bonjour olivia de lasteyrie vous êtes la
directrice d'île de france europe ici à
bruxelles pourquoi est ce que c'est
important pour une région d'être
représentés auprès de l'union européenne
alors c'est essentiel puisque comme
comme peu de gens le réalise finalement
les législations européennes ont un
impact très fort sur à peu près toutes
les législations française puis qu'à peu
près 80% des législations française
découle de règlement ou de directive
européen
et un certain nombre d'entre elles
touchent directement aux compétences des
régions notamment par exemple le
développement économique et donc les
régions ont tout intérêt à être présente
à bruxelles pour savoir ce qui se
prépare en influence est influencé par
dans les travaux des institutions
européennes et ensuite bénéficié autant
que possible des opportunités qui vont
se présenter vous savez plusieurs
missions ici à bruxelles la première on
imagine que c'est de faire le lien entre
donc l'union européenne et la région me
dis qu'il ya des décisions prises ici
qu'est ce que vous faites vous alerter
vous s'échanger avec les représentants
de la région mais alors d'abord un petit
réalisé que non on représente le conseil
régional mais aussi des départements
franciliens on a cette double casquette
il y a également des établissements
publics franciliens qui peuvent être
membre observateur de notre association
c'est le cas d'ile-de-france mobilité
donc on représentant total sept membres
auprès des institutions européennes en
tant que bureau de représentation
on a
trois missions la première c'est de
faire de la veille bien sûr sur tout ce
qui est entrepris à bruxelles la
deuxième c'est de permettre à l'île de
france de bénéficier de financements
européens les financements de la
politique de cohésion le feder le fonds
social européen etc mais pas que puisque
aussi tous les grands programmes de
financement comme horizon europe
life le mécanisme pour l'interconnexion
en europe erasmus
et ça on veille à ce que les
collectivités membres de l'association
en bénéficient mais pas seulement on
travaille aussi au service des acteurs
franciliens pour l'ensemble de la région
quels sont les thèmes forts qui les
principaux thèmes qui intéressent la
région d'après du développement
économique des transports s'il y en a
d'autres oui alors juste pour bien sûr
une dernière mission d'abord c'est
l'affluence tout simplement des
stratégies d' influence sur justement
les politiques les plus importants donc
je viens c'est politique on suit une
dizaine de politiques qui sont liées
donc aux compétences de la région et des
départements donc je mentionnais tout à
l'heure effectivement le développement
économique est essentiel notamment
toutes les questions de recherche
innovation de numérique et aussi les
transports et la mobilité surtout pour
la région ile de france où les la
compétence appartient à la région il y a
également tout ce qui concerne les
questions d'environnement énergie climat
ce qui est très vaste bien sûr la
politique de cohésion que je citais
également plus pour les départements les
questions emploi affaires sociales
notamment la santé qui montrent de plus
en plus sur l'agenda européen on suit
aussi de très près les questions liées
au tourisme sujets essentiels pour l'île
de france et là aussi dans le cadre d'un
ferme sous l'angle pardon du
développement économique et la culture
yens l'union européenne elle peut
sembler loin parfois d'eux des citoyens
votre mission souci de te faire ce lien
de la rapprocher avec les franciliens
pour que cette barrière administrative
qu'on entend souvent ne soit pas un
frein au projet
oui alors nous ce qu'on essaye de faire
surtout c'est de rassurer les gens qui
ont envie de s'engager et qui prennent
contact avec les services europe des
département ou de la région pour l'heure
leur donner des conseils les
aiguillonner vers les bonnes personnes
au sein des institutions et en fait ce
dont on se rencontre généralement c'est
qu'en fait les institutions européennes
sont très ouvertes d'après ce qu'on nous
dit bien plus que les autorités
françaises par exemple que en fait quand
on demande un rendez-vous à la
commission européenne si on cible la
bonne personne et qu'on a des choses
intéressantes à lui dire y'a jamais
difficultés à obtenir un rendez vous au
contraire les aînés ralement dans les
institutions les gens sont très
demandeurs d'avoir des retours
d'expérience de savoir comment ça se
passe sur le terrain comment les
initiatives sont perçus
comment les financements sont utilisés
et c'est donc finalement les
institutions à tous les niveaux que ce
soit au niveau politique ou au niveau
technique sont généralement demandeuse
des changes avec avec des acteurs ou des
collectivités locales sur les
financements on connaît la le fonds
européen de développement régional feder
on imagine que vous travaillez un peu
avec ce ce fonds est at il d'autres
fonds sur lesquels vous travaillez
beaucoup en fait le feder relève donc de
la politique de cohésion il ya aussi le
fonds social européen est en fait l'île
de france est la seule région française
qui bénéficie de plus de f est ce que de
feder et ça cet argent est géré
directement par la région qui est
autorité de gestion et donc nous sur ce
sujet là on est surtout intervenue au
moment où les règlements qui encadrent
la politique de cohésion pour la
nouvelle programmation donc la période
2021 et 2027 était en cours
d'élaboration puis de négociation
interinstitutionnelles et là on a et
veiller à ce que les intérêts d'une
région comme l'île de france qui fait
partie de la catégorie des régions les
plus développées soit bien pris en
compte dans les règlements après sur
l'utilisation des fonds elle même c'est
la région qui intervient et nous on est
plus en derrière pour avoir la toile de
fond pour leur donner des informations
sur la façon dont la politique de
cohésion est susceptible d'évoluer à
l'avenir ce que vous avez des exemples
de projets qui vous avez accompagné qui
ont pu aboutir grâce à des fonds
européens oui fait l'an dernier on a
accompagné une vingtaine de porteurs de
projets en lien avec l'équipe les
équipes du conseil régional qui ont il
ya aussi une équipe dédiée à ça donc on
a un partage des tâches entre le conseil
régional et nous et sur ses porteurs de
projets y en a huit qui ont bénéficié de
financements notamment par exemple
ile-de-france mobilité et la ratp qui
ont reçu 23 millions d'euros dans le
cadre du mécanisme pour l'interconnexion
en europe qui permettra de financer le
renouvellement de la flotte de bus
franciliens et des infrastructures de
recharge dont vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure de de lobbying concrètement
comment est ce que vous faites au
quotidien pour pour influencer sur les
décisions qui sont prises ici
concrètement dès qu'on identifie un
enjeu potentiel un besoin qui aurait pas
été pris en compte on contacte les
services compétents à la région ou dans
les départements ou auprès
d'ile-de-france mobilité on se met
d'accord avec eux sur les messages à
faire passer et puis on prend contact
avec la personne qui quand on est au
tout début qui tient la plume à la
commission européenne pour puisque
évidemment plus on intervient tôt plus
on a de chances que ça marche et ensuite
une fois que la proposition de la
commission ont été publiés on relaie
aussi ses messages auprès des députés
européens qu'ils soient impliqués sur le
sujet donc les rapporteurs les shadows
rapporteur on travaille avec des députés
toutes nationalités confondues ça c'est
très important et de tous groupes
politiques confondus et et puis on a
aussi des relations étroites avec un
présentation permanente de la france
pour avoir des informations sur la façon
dont les négociations se déroulent au
conseil et sur les positions qui se
dessine de ce côté là parce que vous
avez également des relations étroites
avec les eurodéputés franciliens
viennent de la région ile de france oui
on essaie d'entretenir des relations
privilégiées avec eux après ça dépend
beaucoup des commissions parlementaires
dans lesquels ils sont impliqués
plusieurs d'entre eux sont impliqués
dans des commissions qui ont un impact
un peu moins directe pour une région
comme la nôtre
donc on travaille en priorité avec eux
avec les députés français en général
mais comme je le mentionnais si on voit
que c'est par exemple un rapporteur
roumain
qui s'occupe du texte c'est évidemment
avec lui qu'on va essayer de travailler
en priorité tout en tenant informé les
français de la commission concerné pour
qu'ils puissent également après appuyer
les positions qui pourraient défendre
vous partagez vos locaux ici à bruxelles
avec l'antenne de la région normandie où
sont-ils si tu es comment sont ils alors
nos âmes situé au coeur du quartier
européen tout près du parlement européen
et
c'est nos présidents de région qui ont
décidé de de regrouper leurs bureaux de
représentation ça montre de manière
d'une manière générale la force du
collectif français à bruxelles en fait
on travaille beaucoup entre régions
françaises on a l'habitude de se
coordonner tous les mois au niveau des
directeurs on a des groupes de travail
thématiques de nos bureaux on en a six
ou sept et on rencontre tous très
régulièrement soit au niveau des
directeurs de bureaux soit au niveau des
chargés de mission sont des groupes de
travail thématiques d un des décideurs
au sein des institutions européennes on
partage énormément d'informations entre
nous on relaie aussi des positions
communes quand par exemple les gens
france a pris des positions on n'hésite
pas à le faire savoir à nos
interlocuteurs donc de manière générale
les régions françaises qui sont toutes
représentées à bruxelles y compris les
rup sont très actives et travaille
collectivement nourrissions dans le
quartier européen à bruxelles c'est
stratégique ce quartier c'est primordial
d'être ici pour justement vos missions
dont on va parler oui ça facilite
énormément le travail parce que déjà
pour des raisons pratiques qu'on est
tout près tout le monde et puis aussi
parce que ça nous permet informellement
de de croiser
on est tous au même endroit on se croise
on discute à chaque occasion alors
évidemment depuis deux ans c'est moins
le cas mais mais sinon oui c'est utile
d'être vraiment là au coeur des choses
toutes les régions françaises sont
représentées ici à vous
merci beaucoup j'ai appris qu'olivier de
lasteyrie d'avoir été avec nous dans une
europe je rappelle que vous êtes la
directrice d'île de france europe
sous drogue ce jour là
ce jour là le 1er janvier 2002 c'est le
passage à l'euro les billets et les
pièces sont introduits dans 12 pays
retour sur un événement historique avec
europe direct
si vous n'êtes plus très jeune vous vous
souvenez sûrement que si vous voulez
voyager à travers l'europe il fallait
absolument prévoir un peu de temps pour
changer votre argent liquide avant le
1er janvier 2002 chaque pays avait sa
devise le franc en france le deutsche
mark en allemagne la lire italienne la
paix c'est en espagne la drachme en
grèce et cetera et cetera c'est allé là
douze pays se lance dans l'aventuré de
l'euro seulement trois pays avaient
préféré conserver leurs monnaies
nationales
le danemark le royaume uni et la suède
l'euro est en effet une révolution
monétaire et sociétal qui a changé notre
manière de vivre et notre relation avec
les autres pays membres en 2021 la
monnaie unique est désormais
parfaitement rentré dans les moeurs mais
on constate quand même des critiques
vivace au sein de notre continent
surtout après la crise économique et
financière qui a eu lieu en 2008 cet
événement a fait déchanter une partie de
la société européenne puisque avec
l'établissement de l'euro nous avons
espéré avoir les reins solides pour
réagir aux chocs économiques mondiaux il
faut dire toutefois qu'en général les
européens restent favorables à l'euro
selon le dernier sondage eurobaromètre
en 2021 80 % des interrogés sont
favorables à l'euro et 76% estiment
qu'il est bénéfique pour leur pays mais
revenons sur les objectifs de cet
ambitieux projet le traité de maastricht
entrée en vigueur en 1992 prévoyait en
effet l'établissement d'une seule devise
pour éliminer au maximum les barrières
économiques entre les pays membres c'est
donc l'un des moyens pour rendre
effectif le marché unique et les quatre
libertés de circulation qui le
caractérise deux personnes de biens
services et capitaux les autorités
européennes estimaient qu'une monnaie
commune à tous les pays étaient
nécessaires pour éliminer les
fluctuations et les frais de change
favoriser la coopération et réduire les
disparités économiques
revers de la médaille qui dit devise
commune dit aussi règles communes des
critères de convergence comme la fameuse
règle du 3% qui fait chaque année
grincer les dons à certains pays membres
- rigoureux en termes de dépenses
publiques au final tous les arguments
s'entendent d'un côté il faut garantir
les services publics pour les citoyens
et accompagner la croissance tandis que
d'un autre côté il est important de
garantir un budget stable en cas de
conjoncture économique négative comme la
crise sanitaire que nous vivons
d'ailleurs c'est logique pourriez vous
vivre avec un colocataire qui jettent
l'argent comment par la fenêtre au bout
d'un moment on dit basta bref
l'équilibré parfois difficile à trouver
des solutions ont été proposées comme
l'instauration d'un vrai fédéralisme
budgétaire ce fonctionnement permettrait
des transferts publics pour réduire les
disparités et atténuer les conséquences
des chocs économiques à ce stade rien
n'est moins sûr pourtant c'est sûr en
2002 avec l'euro nous sommes devenu plus
européen les mains dans les poches
sonos robe l'invité politique
je reçois aujourd'hui l'eurodéputé ian
christophe eu jane eurodéputés allemands
membres du groupe renault europe vice
président de la commission des
transports et du tourisme
bonjour bonjour alors 2021 c'est l'année
européenne du rail alors un train à
sillonner toute l'europe entre septembre
et octobre c'était le connecting express
objectif promouvoir le train auprès des
citoyens européens est aussi une vraie
mobilité durable est-ce que vous pensez
que le train est vraiment négligé dans
l'est dans les trajets qu'ils soient du
quotidien ou pour des trajets un peu
plus
éphémère pour des vacances ou autre le
train a son rôle et il ya énormément de
gens qui prennent le train et
heureusement parce que le train est
important notamment dans les zones
urbaines pour transporter les personnes
qui vont au travail
donc ça c'est très important et c'est
assez un rôle clé dans le transport
parce que imaginer la région parisienne
sont sans rer ça marcherait pas qu'avec
des voitures donc heureusement qu'on a
le train et qu'il est apprécié après la
grande question c'est comment est-ce
qu'on peut promouvoir le train et le
fait de nous l'idée de prendre plus le
train et de laisser la voiture à la
maison et je pense pour pour cela il
faut que le service soit bon que le
produit est bon que les gens aient envie
de prendre le train c'est pas toujours
le cas on parle souvent des retards y
avait il ya les retards il ya les
l'équipement des trains mais ce qu'on
peut travailler dans le train si on fait
un trajet tout ça c'est important
si on veut que le train soit une vraie
alternative à la voiture ou à l'avion
alors on l'a vu en france une
interdiction est tombée les certaines
liaisons aériennes intérieures sont
interdites en cas d'alternatives en
train de moins de deux heures et demie
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est une
bonne ou une mauvaise solution d'imposer
on va dire finalement le trajet en train
à la place de l'avion c'est une solution
qui est prise en france pour une
situation française
en france vous avez les lignes grande
vitesse
vous avez des connexions avec les
aéroports
le système du train est plutôt bien
développée en allemagne je suis moi je
suis allemand donc je peux comparer on a
un système du trinquet où on n'a pas de
ligne grande vitesse on a plutôt des
connexions qui sont pas lente mais le
nôtre notre tgv à nous le hisser eux ils
roulent moins vite que le tgv et il fait
plus de stop
du coup là
on ne peut pas comparer ces deux
situations donc je pense qu'il faut à
l'échelle nationale
trouver un bon fonctionnement et avoir
la possibilité de faire la connexion
entre le train et l'avion parce que vous
allez pas en train dans les états unis
où ou en asie donc donc il faut la
connexion avec avec la viande et au
moment où c'est possible vous pouvez
remplacer des trajets courts trajets
courts par le train mais si ce n'est pas
possible
voilà il vous faut des avions avec des
call avec des trajets courts pour faire
la liaison avec avec
les aéroport donc c'est une question de
comment
le réseau est ce qu on a les bonnes
connexions entre les différents modes
transports alors vous disiez tout à
l'heure est ce qu'on peut travailler
dans le train et des fois les gens ont
l'impression de perdre leur temps dans
le dans le train le trans europe express
vous en avez sans doute entendu parler
le développement des trains de nuit par
exemple le paris vienne qui partira à
partir du 13 décembre est-ce que c'est
des initiatives qui cette fois ci
pourrait être payante car
potentiellement la nuit les gens dorment
et ont l'impression de ne pas perdre
leur temps cette fois ci c'est une
nouvelle magnifique que il ya à nouveau
le train de nuit et j'espère que bientôt
on aura également un train de nuit paris
berlin ça serait ça serait une bonne
nouvelle
ce serait une décision très forte ce
serait une décision très forte et un
symbole très fort également après il
faut que ce soit un bon produit un bon
service si vous avez en train qui vous
fait arriver à votre destination qu'à 11
heures du matin vous loupez de trois
heures du monde pendant la matinée où
vous pouvez faire des réunions donc ça
serait pas acceptée par parce qu'ils qui
veulent utiliser le train donc il faut
un bon produit qui
qui est à l' encontre à la rencontre de
des demandes des passagers à ce moment
là c'est une c'est une super solutions
et
à la condition au long terme
il ya assez de gens qui le qu'il prenne
et que que d'un point de vue financier
ça soit rentable alors on parle des
passagers mais outre le transport de
passagers il ya aussi le fret qui est
une grande majorité finalement des
déplacements en avion aussi par la route
comment est ce qu'on pourrait faire pour
que le fret soit plus exploités au
niveau du chemin de fer par exemple on a
déjà une très bonne situation dans le
dans le fret
il ya à mon avis de point où on doit
s'améliorer premièrement c'est la
digitalisation dans beaucoup de pays
notamment dans le centre de l'europe on
n'a pas assez de capacité capacités sur
les chemins de fer donc il nous faut un
système digital
qui nous améliore qui nous permet
d'améliorer
l'utilisation des chemins de fer et
comme ça on peut augmenter la capacité
de 10 à 20% ça serait un premier pas et
deuxièmement
la grande question c'est comment est ce
qu'on fait à la fin du trajet et parfois
il ya la connexion dont dans les ports
ça existe dans certaines régions en
france on peut s'améliorer encore
et c'est important d'avoir cette
connexion après l'arrivée des containers
par exemple dans les ports européens
d'avoir la connexion directement avec le
avec le rail est au bout d'avoir des des
bonnes connexions entre la route et les
chemins de fer parce que vous n'allez
pas pouvoir a mené le train partout il
faut bout d'un moment il n'arrivera pas
dans votre supermarché ça c'est ça que
ça soit transporté par par des camions
mais moins de camions possible ces deux
buts alors l'europe a fixé un plan zéro
pollution d'ici 2050 c'est dans le cadre
du fameux pacte vert est un objectif
réaliste selon vous et surtout comment
aider les rôles et les européens dans
les différents pays à s'y préparer et à
parvenir à cet objectif
c'est un objectif ambitieux et je pense
réalisable oui je pense
après faut faut se donner les moyens il
faut faire des efforts et ça sera pas
gratuit
pour pour moi c'est important que dans
cette transition on est de ceux qui ont
des difficultés et ça sera plus
difficile dans les zones rurales que
dans les zones urbaines
c
c'est évident ça sera plus compliqué
compliqué dans les pays de l'est que
dans les pays de l'ouest de l'europe
donc à mon avis il faut aider cette
peine pour cette transition au niveau au
niveau européen après
les
conflits de l'est les entreprises qui
produisent les voitures on déjà décidées
ont annoncé la fin des du moteur à
combustion interne donc on va vers
l'électrique dans les dents les voitures
mais sans excès d'une solution d'avenir
ou de transition l'électrique en voiture
non c'est une solution d'avenir je suis
je suis persuadé après ça à mon avis ça
ne suffit pas parce que là encore il
faut que en est une bonne connexion
entre les modes de transport qui sont
individuelles avec les modes de
transport vous pensez qu'il faut revoir
sa façon d'utiliser la voiture utilisé
sa voiture pour faire 800 km on le fera
plus à me sauver on ira en transport en
commun à la gare en sortant de la gare
on louera peut-être une voiture
électrique qui aura une autonomie de 2 3
4 500 km pour son lieu de vacances ou
son lieu de travail oui je pense je
pense qu'on aura plus de d'options de
mobilité partagée
et c'est une bonne chose il ya de moins
en moins de de gens qui possèdent une
voiture c'est comme ça c'est dans le
sens de l'histoire après il faut que ça
soit praticable et je pense au moment où
ces praticable et où ses confortables
pour les pour les passagers pour ceux
qui utilisent les moyens de transport il
accepte ça au moment où c'est compliqué
où on ne peut pas en parler des trains
tout à l'heure où on ne peut pas se fier
à ce que le train arrive vraiment à
l'heure et qu'on est là la connexion ils
vont se dire bonjour en voiture donc
donc tout va ensemble et il faut un
paquet ou à la fin ça soit où les
consommateurs adhère à 7,7 nouveau
nouvelle ces nouveaux moyens de
transport avant de se quitter un moment
sur la conférence sur l'avenir de
l'europe alors une plate forme a été
mise en place qui permet aux citoyens
européens de s'exprimer future rue point
europa.eu pour vous à quoi ressemblerait
l'europe de demain et l'europe idéal
l'europe idéal c'est une europe qui agit
et démocratique qui a dé cision rapide
qui attaque
traite les points importants qui sont
demandées par nos concitoyens
c'est la crise du climat c'est également
les questions autour de la migration
c'est latence la défense et un marché
intérieur qui est qui est fort parce que
c'est ça notre force et qui fait que
l'europe a du pouvoir au monde donc je
pense que c'est une europe qui est plus
rapide c'est surtout c'est surtout ça et
on doit tous améliorés sur cette
question très bien merci beaucoup et jan
christoph heusgen d'avoir été avec nous
je rappelle que vous êtes eurodéputés
allemands membres du groupe renault
europe et vice président de la
commission des transports et du tourisme
sous d'europe
les superstitions en europe avec evelyne
keller auteur du livre 300 une
superstition petite encyclopédie des
peurs et sagesse populaire celle
opportun on s'intéresse cette semaine au
be le gui c'est encore une
superstition une tradition pour ne
servent aujourd'hui dans les maisons
pour la saint sylvestre cette
croyance
porte bonheur du gui il faut remonter
chez les celtes et l'époque druidique
pour que le gui porte-bonheur fallait
qu'ils soient
recueillies par un druide qui aller le
cueillir avec une faucille en or et il
fallait qu'on l'aide avec un drap en
dessous parce que le guide ne devaient
pas toucher le sol
et à partir de ce moment là le guide
s'est paré de vertus oubliées même faire
trente et une nuits parce qu'on allait
avec cet os
obtenir une eau miraculeuse qui toute
l'année
permettrait de guérir les petits bobos
donc ceux qui aujourd'hui on va le
mettre à l'entrée d'une maison
la tradition voudrait que l'on
s'embrasse avant minuit faire douze
coups de minuit une autre tradition qui
dit qu
il faut se dépêcher quand celui de
s'embrasser sous lui mais il faut qu'ils
soient tout de suite décroché après faut
pas qu'il reste dans la maison parce que
la vie fort sumner donc il faut aller se
débarrasser de ceux qui portent butt il
avait un geste qui portait qui étaient
néfastes pour celui qui le commet tenait
il ne faut jamais débarrassé un arbre de
tous on dit il faut juste prendre six
dont on a besoin il leur apporte à la
maison zone europe c'est terminé pour
aujourd'hui merci aux équipes techniques
du parlement européen de bruxelles vous
pouvez retrouver cette émission en
podcast audio et vidéo sur notre site et
notre application radio sensations et
aussi sur tv 78 rendez vous la semaine
prochaine très bonne soirée
zone europe / sensations
zone europe avec le soutien financier de
la région ile de france